[Music]
hello and welcome to playstation grenade
fortnite season six drop today and as is
our three year mission now this
is the video series which runs through
all the map changes
later this week i will also have a bunch
of new videos all about fortnite law
so please think about hitting subscribe
if you are new
also shameless code adam arrow plug here
thanks much lee
okay so chapter two season six week one
let's do this
so the zero point has been contained
once again this time by the leader of
the seven
the foundation how cool was that opening
mission i spotted a ton of things you
need to know about it
but let's deal with the aftermath first
the ceiling of the zero point
caused autumn to fall over six areas of
the map
at each of these points is a spire with
a launch pad
to enjoy at the top at each of these
points is a guardian who protects the
spire with their life
and here's the cool part by eliminating
the guard you'll be able to pick up this
object which harnesses dark energy
seemingly to jump higher
well did you know that if you take that
object all the way to the central spire
it will be linked to one of the ritual
spots place the object in there
to receive the spire jump boots these
things can be powered up by jumping
repeatedly
and on the third jump we can dive into a
glider redeploy
now that is a map update with
consequences i love it
and i guess we just wait and see what
the community do with this item now
i was wondering if the boots would
prevent fall damage for meme
potential but um no you go you go splat
here's a myth chaser question what do
you think will happen if we take
all those orbs to the center spire myth
chasers we've got work to do
at each of the new spire locations are
buildings which are very similar to each
other so we won't be going over every
location
but some of them are unique for example
have you visited the colosseum recently
it's an absolute ruin the stone and
concrete has been broken
and crops now fill the former fighting
pit
gotta love this touch peely statue has
been turned into a triceratops lord
i would totally buy that skin inside the
ruins are now cave paintings
including a rio style uppercut to a
dinosaur
if this is a glimpse into what comes
next then count me in
i want to fight dinosaurs and shut the
front door
what the heck are these at various
points around the island are dinosaur
eggs
there's a satisfying splat when you
melee them which indicates
these eggs are the real deal could we be
getting a dinosaur themed update
last time eggs like this were here they
hatched into the hybrid character
dinosaurs would totally fit this time
period wherein this primal age is the
foundation
of human life
[Music]
here's an interesting little addition to
season six over by the pipe man and hey
man smashing out the high five
is a brand new building it's relatively
modern too
there are blacked out curtains
suggesting something is awry inside
but everything seems to be okay it looks
like there's some sort of power outage
right now as candles make up the main
light source here
one of the rooms is labeled no entry
it's a bedroom of course
posters are on the wall for old epic
games like jazz jackrabbit
shadow complex and one must fall and
look
there's a new misfit bear to keep an eye
on last christmas these bears came to
life
and attempted a coup over the gnomes it
probably won't happen again
but i'll keep an eye on this guy all the
same
hang on graham is he still there
oh yes graham our lord and savior
continues to watch over us
and once again the gnomes have an update
deep in the basement of the grenade
radio station is a new spectacle to
feast your eyes on
graham is in the studio laying down new
beats for an upcoming track
set to blow your mind i tried out for a
roll on the song
and uh it was a no from graham thanks
mate
oh well a small change which is likely
to upgrade over the season
is outside lazy lake by the waterfall
there's a new sheriff in town
well it's the old sheriff in the new
town this update
removed the old jail house which we
found in the desert and now this place
is the new spot
for law and order it's non-existent
right now just a few supplies and a tent
i think this will expand over the next
few updates i really hope it does
over by pleasant park do you remember
the grumpy bush which sat
outside well that's been updated and
it's now
a stone face instead it's a small easter
egg
but definitely worth mentioning
[Music]
last season we talked about the
convergence points of interest from the
first map being brought back
like flush factory and the der burger
well a few of those new spots
took a hit today look at the dusty
containers right now
they've been all but destroyed i guess
the convergence
is on hold for another season can we
take a moment to appreciate the green
return of risky reels
this place has been through so much and
last season it sat
under sand this season there are much
less vehicles but other than that
risky reels is back just like day one of
chapter two
an update which is not so great occurs
up at tomato town
can you spot it it's earth shattering
isn't it yeah
the tomato head no longer spins round i
am absolutely devastated
but i also remember what happened the
last time the head stopped spinning
it completely vanished and two years
later it reappeared
in the woods hopefully the spinny head
will come back because other than this
pizza pit is looking good right now no
longer buried in sand
super clean and ready for a grand
reopening
as well as gaining new pois this season
we've also lost a few
namely hunter's haven now reduced to a
neanderthal village
this is one of the places the dinosaur
eggs can be found i also found this
interesting
remember the ritual sites found
everywhere on the island
well this season there are a ton more to
be found
each one with offerings to plunder i
made a video a long time ago about how
these will likely be more important in
future seasons
and maybe this is that season so far
only thor has used them to summon his
lightning and thunder powers
so every update since 2019 i have made
my way down to the redacted bunker and
hope
for a change and finally after almost
two years
we have an update surprisingly it isn't
the bunker itself
it's right next door it's a small
building to the right open this up
and you'll spot this one of the old
vaults from season two
that was a good season a word above can
be read
b-o-o i'm not sure how many holes are
there anyway boom
suggesting that this is linked to tn
tina we can't get inside right now but
we can shift to see a rift shard here
i'm guessing this is part of the skin
unlocks for jonesy
it's maybe a huge part of the law too
which has me thinking so over the next
few days
i'm going to be talking to all the npcs
on the map to find out clues about the
story
so be sure to check back in a few days
we'll break this story wide open
together
so lazy lake looks to be the same as
last season still no update to the
insurance building
i've loki been waiting for a new diorama
to be placed here since 2019
but there is a change to be found get
your butt down to where midas gold
toilet was last season
you'll find that it's gone but now break
through the joining basement and you'll
find
a new room a secret archive of art but
wait something is missing here
a display cabinet in the middle with
nothing inside
this for sure must be linked to a quest
line
anyone want to guess what will end up
here in fact maybe we should try putting
one of the spire orbs here
not to self over to the former sweaty
drop spots
salty towers now and it's now bony burbs
am i saying that right
the clock tower has survived but alas on
day one of the season
it does not function anymore well at
least not for me
the buildings here are all adapted from
what was left behind from the previous
buildings
rather than new ones at other locations
the coolest update to me
are the bridges in the primal zones the
former structures are now fortilla-like
living spaces and remind me a lot of mad
max
and to add to this the lord of the rings
aesthetic from the tower spires
things are becoming quite apocalyptic
sadly in this update we've lost access
to the i o bunkers under the map
stealthy stronghold is solid ground
again as are all the other old locations
i even checked under the map and can
confirm there is no
sub-terrain elements in this season's
update and finally there are legendary
loot stashes on the island again this
season and they look like this
i bring this up because i don't know why
it says week 7 on top
are they linked to the secret skin maybe
what do the numbers mean
mason
so there we have it what did i miss
everything that's changed on the map
in week one of chapter two season six
big or small if you spot anything please
put them in the comments below and i'll
be sure to talk about them next time
around
also if you've noticed anything in the
event which you'd like me to talk about
again let me know below so far i'm
loving season six
but i do miss the snipers already what
about you what do you think
a big thanks if you've stuck around this
far and here's a bunch of legends who've
used code adamaru at the end of last
season
it's much appreciated and allows me to
keep making videos like this
thank you so much i'm adam from
playstation grenade you're awesome
i'll see you next time
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]